Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass in unserer 199. Ausgabe. Jaja, reden wir über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Wir werden einen Schwerpunkt legen auf dem SC Paderborn und auf dem KSRO SC. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, hier im Rasenfunk-Kurzpass Nr. 199. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer bei Twitter und ich freue mich sehr, zwei Gäste hier begrüßen zu dürfen. Zum einen Marie, sie ist die Ed Risikso auf Twitter. Sie ist KSC-Fan, vielleicht kennt ihr sie auch schon aus der Saisonvorschau von Melanthoen. Hallo Marie. Sehr schön, dass du hier mit dabei bist. Und ebenso freue ich mich über Marco Kornrumpf, Kornrumpf, Entschuldigung, bitte, vom Padercast, der Edmr Kornrumpf auf Twitter. Da konnte ich es jetzt gleich nochmal üben. Danke dir dafür.
Ja, ich glaube, damit kann man zufrieden sein, wenn man aufsteigt und sich dann in der Liga hält. Es ist schon wirklich interessant, allein die Träne, über die wir in diesem Kurzpass hier gesprochen haben, wie unterschiedlich sie sind. Quas New York-Eichener, jetzt dann eben mit Jens Härtel, jemanden, der eben auch sich sehr am Gegner orientiert, sehr gutes Ingame-Coaching hat, sehr oft auch die Formation wechselt. Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, aber wenn man jetzt weiß, wie gut ich mich mit den Sportdirektoren auskenne in der 2. Männer Bundesliga, muss man das mit Vorsicht genießen. Aber manchmal habe ich den Eindruck, in der 2. Liga geschehen gerade auf der Trainerposition mehr Innovationen und mehr ein Hinwenden zum Modernen als in der 1. Bundesliga. Ich stelle das einfach mal so in den Raum. Das ist so mein Gefühl.
Du hast halt super viel Innovationsbedarf in der 2. Liga, um dich zu differenzieren, weil wenn du auch siehst, wie eng teilweise die Spiele zusammen sind, egal ob das jetzt ein Werder Bremen ist, ein HSV ist, oder ob das jetzt ein Nürnberg, Heidenheim oder auch ein Rostock ist. Ich glaube, man sagt ja vielfach, und das zeigt ja auch die Tabelle im großen Teil, bei der Hinrunde vielleicht noch viel mehr als jetzt gerade in der Rückrunde, die Teams liegen gar nicht so weit voneinander entfernt. Also jeder kann jeden schlagen, sagt man ja immer. Und man hat ja auch immer wieder einen Ausreißer drin, dass auf einmal ein vermeintlicher Favorit eine Schlappe einstecken muss. Und ich glaube, dass das auch ganz viel mit den Leuten auf der Bank zu tun hat. Also ich glaube, dass noch viel mehr Innovation auf der Bank, wie du es gerade auch schon gesagt hast, als in der ersten Liga. Auch notwendig, um sich zu differenzieren. Und vor allen Dingen hast du viele hungrige Trainer. Also das sind ja alles Leute, die das nicht als ihre Karriereende ansehen, würde ich mal so sagen, oder größtenteils, sagen wir es mal so.
Der umgedrehte Maggarteffekt in der 2. Bundesliga ist zu beobachten. Was können wir denn dann Marie über Holstein-Kiel festhalten? Auch da gab es ja einen viel diskutierten Trainerwechsel ohne Werner. Jetzt ist Marse Rapp da am Ruder. Holstein liegt gerade mit 34 Punkten Punkt, gleich mit Hansel Rostock dann eben auch 6 Punkte vor den Abstiegsrennen. Hatte jetzt aber wirklich eine schlechte Phase, die am Wochenende endlich durchbrochen werden konnte mit einem Sieg?
Ja, ich glaube bei Kiel ist es auch einfach so, dass sie in den letzten Jahren dann oftmals irgendwelche Abgänge zurückstecken mussten. Sei es jetzt auch letzte Saison mit dem Trainer, wie du den gerade angesprochen hast. Ich glaube, die mussten sich immer wieder ziemlich neu orientieren. Ja, ich bin immer wieder fasziniert, wenn ich mir aktuell den Kader anschaue. Ich habe mir jetzt mal kurz angeschaut, auch einfach. Dann haben sie Fiete Arb im Kader oder Reese, die oftmals einfach als Talente noch vor ein paar Jahren gehandelt wurden, aber dann doch nicht den Durchbruch geschafft haben. Ja, den wollte ich gerade erwähnen. Ich wollte mit den jungen Leuten anfangen. Dann haben sie aber daneben noch einen Louis Holtby dann plötzlich aus der Versenkung geholt. Ganz komisch, da hat auch jeder geschaut, was macht der jetzt plötzlich wieder noch? Ja, also ich glaube, die wollen auch einfach die Saison jetzt im Endeffekt einfach nur abschließen und dann neue Saison, neues Glück vielleicht.
Marco, wie siehst du die Lage bei Ki?
Ja, ähnlich. Ich glaube auch, dass die, ich glaube, die brauchen auch ein paar Punkte, um wirklich von unten wegzukommen, weil Dynamo Dresden ist ja jetzt nicht so weit weg, 28 zu 34. Aber ich glaube auch, dass die sich gut stabilisiert haben mit Marcel Rapp. Also das hat ganz gut funktioniert. Ich glaube, das tat dem Kader auch gut, dass Ono Werner im Endeffekt, ich glaube er hat ja aufgehört, hat ja sozusagen Abstand genommen von dem Amt. Ich glaube, das hat dem Kader auch gut getan. Ich glaube, der Kader ist nach wie vor im Unbruch. Also es sind ja viele ältere Herren dort auch unterwegs, Finn Bartels, Holpi. Ich glaube, der Arp verlässt auch nach Ende der Saison Kiel, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe. Ich glaube, es ist eine Mannschaft im Umbruch gerade. Wir haben jetzt zwei Saison, glaube ich, ziemlich aktiv oben mitgespielt, sind jetzt ein bisschen im Umbruch gerade. Ja, würde mich freuen, wenn die sich stabilisieren, weil ich war auch noch nie auswärts in Kiel, da möchte ich unbedingt mal hin.
Ja, ich bin ehrlich gesagt bei Kiel einfach nur gespannt, was die nächsten Wochen noch bringen. Denn wenn ich aufs Restprogramm gucke, da gibt es schon die Gefahr, finde ich, noch mal reinzurutschen. Und jetzt am Wochenende eben, das war der erste Sieg nach vier Niederlagen in Folge. Man spielt jetzt zunächst gegen Darmstadt, dann gegen Hamburg und dann gegen den direkten Abstiegskampf-Konkurrenten Dresden. Will jetzt nicht irgendwie das Schwarze an die Wand malen. Es geht aber dann auch nicht so arg wie besser weiter. Also Heidenheim, Werder, Nürnberg und dann noch Sandhausen ganz hinten raus. Kann auch sein, dass –also meinem Gefühl nach Ligen, Holstein –diese Begegnung vielleicht sogar manchmal besser. Da holt man sich dann einen überraschenden Punkt und manchmal vielleicht sogar einen Sieg gegen einen großen Namen. Aber nur auf dem Papier gesehen ist die Situation, also die Saison ist noch nicht vorbei. Während wir bei euren beiden Vereinen mit drei Punkten mehr da relativ entspannt waren, würde ich sagen, na, Rostock und Kiel, die sollten jetzt ihre Grundspannung da jetzt nicht komplett aufgeben. Sonst könnte das vielleicht enger werden.
Wobei es sich ja meistens gegen vermeintliche stärkere Gegner leichter spielt, als wenn du jetzt wie Kiel am Wochenende gegen Ingolstadt so ein –ja, wenn du gegen die Keller-Kinder spielst, dann ist es glaube ich immer ein bisschen schwieriger noch zu spielen und selbst das Spiel zu machen, als wenn du als Underdog in ein Spiel gegen HSV reingehst.
Als ich es gesagt habe, ist es mir selbst aufgefallen, dass das jetzt nicht so die Neuigkeit ist für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, dass es so ist. Aber das baut uns ja die Brücke zu eben genau jenem Ingolstadt. Das ist die letzte Mannschaft, über die wir noch sprechen wollen. Marie, ich glaube, da muss man nach der Grundspannung jetzt nicht mehr fragen. In 13 Punkte Rückstand, letzter Tabellenplatz. Wir haben darüber jetzt auch schon mehrfach gesprochen, hier in den Kurzpässen zur 2. Bundesliga. Das hat sich jetzt nicht ganz so überraschend entwickelt, würde ich sagen, auch für alle Ingolstädter, obwohl man ja durchaus noch so ein paar Dinge verändert hat. Wie gefällt dir denn der FCI, wenn du jetzt einfach mal so auf die letzten Wochen blickst?
Ja, also, ich kann mit Ingolstadt an sich… Also es gibt so Vereine in der Liga, mit denen ich eigentlich einfach nicht viel anfangen. Und Ingolstadt ist halt nun mal einfach so ein Verein. Ja, ich glaube, das Spannendste wird bei Ingolstadt jetzt einmal noch sein, ob sie vielleicht noch mal einen von den großen Ärgern können, die oben vielleicht mitspielen, sei es jetzt den HSV beispielsweise noch. Aber ja, ich glaube, die wissen selber eigentlich, dass sie abgestiegen sind, jetzt gerade auch mit dem Rückstand, den sie haben. Jetzt auch gerade nach der Niederlage gegen Kiel, wo sie vielleicht dann doch immer ein bisschen Hoffnung hatten. Aber ja, sie wissen es glaube ich selber einfach, dass es nicht mehr wirklich realistisch ist, dass noch die Liga halten werden.
Dementsprechend stellen sie ja auch ihren Kader auf. Viele Spieler aus der U23, viele aus der dritten Liga noch mit dabei. Also das wirkt auf mich so, Marco, vielleicht auch ein bisschen im Kontrast zum SC Paderborn damals, wie ein Drittligist, der den Aufstieg geschafft hat, der aber im Grunde weiter so ein bisschen als Drittligist in der zweiten Liga spielt.
Ich glaube, bei Ingolstadt ist der Drops gelutscht. Und ich glaube, das ist auch nochmal ein gutes Beispiel. Wir hatten ja vorhin über diese Trainer-Rotation bei Schalke gesprochen. Ich meine, schaut euch an, was bei Ingolstadt passiert ist dieses Jahr. Petsold, Schubert, Rehm. Und wenn du halt die Qualität dann nicht im Kader hast, dass ein Tirodde dir einfach die Siege schießt oder in Summe die Kaderqualität gut ist, stehst du dann halt bei so einer Rotation auch ganz weit unten. Wobei, ich bin da schon bei dir, also ich glaube, dass Ingolstadt von Anfang an nicht so aufgestellt war, dass sie irgendwie gesichert gegen den Klassenerhalt entgegen marschiert sind. Also, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie der Tabellenverlauf war, aber ich glaube, dass man dort, ja, also schon von Anfang an arg um den Klassenerhalt bibbern musste.
Ja, es gab nur einen Spieltag, an dem man nicht auf einem der letzten drei Plätze lag. Das war am zweiten Spieltag.
Also, wenn man das zum Beispiel mit Dynamo Dresden vergleicht, ich glaube, Dresden hat sich da deutlich besser aufgestellt als Ingolstadt. Ich weiß nicht, wie es finanziell um Ingolstadt steht. Das ist ja auch, glaube ich, ein sehr stark sponsorigen, abhängiger Verein. Der, ja, aber ich glaube, genau, es geht in die dritte Liga und das ist auch gut so. Und es ist ja okay, wenn man jetzt an Reben festhält und sich versucht dann für die dritte Liga aufzustellen.
Ja, also Ingolstadt, du hast es ja angesprochen, mit einem Automobilhersteller in der eigenen Stadt, anders situiert als andere Vereine bei den Verbindlichkeiten, zum Beispiel auf Rang 2, der kompletten Profi-Verein. Also man hat eben eigentlich kaum Schulden, aber logischerweise ist der Etat, der Personalaufwand, das ist alles. Da ist man ganz weit hinten in der Tabelle, die man da aufstellen kann. Und das ist ja vielleicht auch sogar ganz wohltuend, dass es auch noch diese Vereine gibt, die zwar auch Finanzkapital hinter sich haben und dadurch einen Standortvorteil haben, der jetzt erstmal nichts mit sportlichen Dingen zu tun hat, die aber dann daraus nicht den Anspruch ableiten, jetzt müssen wir in die erste Liga oder weit in der zweiten Liga mitspielen, sondern sie haben sich so ihr eigenes Profil erarbeitet. Mit einer Jugendarbeit, auch mit einer spielerischen Ausrichtung hatten ja auch schon den ein oder anderen interessanten Trainer, der es von dort aus dann geschafft hat, in noch größere Weinen, höhere Weinen des Profi-Fußballs zu kommen. Ich glaube, das ist die Rolle von Ingolstadt. Da haben wir jetzt noch mal eine große Fass aufgemacht. Ganz am Schluss. Ihr zwei, ich danke euch sehr herzlich. Das hat, wie immer, große Freude gemacht, mit euch über die zweite Bundesliga zu sprechen. Ich kann allen daraus nur empfehlen, euch zu folgen. Auf Twitter, Marie heißt da et Risixo. Risixo? Es ist wie Risico nur mit X. Meine Güte. Marie, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst. Und danke ebenfalls an Marco Kornrumpf vom Padercast, der et MA Kornrumpf, auf Twitter. Danke dir, lieber Marco.
Ja, vielen Dank für die Einladung und hat mir sehr viel Spaß mit euch beiden gemacht.
Das freut mich. Ich wünsche euch allen eine gute Zeit und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Unter rasenfunk.de/supportersclubkönnt ihr nachschauen, wie man das tut und auch schon die kleinen Beträge helfen. Die summieren sich auf. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Unterstützung. Es lohnt sich auch in den nächsten Tagen mal unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de reinzugucken. Da wird nämlich unsere neue Tasse veröffentlicht. Und dann hören wir uns hoffentlich bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund und macht es gut.